Thursday night in a central London dance
theater tickets are selling crowds are
building they're here to see a
contemporary dance show in the mind of
eagle every person here is a source of
data what if you may occasionally have a
blockbuster but then you'll also have
something that's quite an issue and
actually finding the right people who
love that show
and fill out the theater becomes quite
hard and that is something we can help
with
Edwina done and her husband Clive humma
me of the brains behind data science
company purple 7 it aims to draw bigger
audiences to mesh art productions using
ticket sales data for more theatres know
about their patrons the easier it is I
quite like comparing it to oil as it
comes out the ground it's not very
useful and it's not - you've refined it
that it becomes valuable and that's the
real challenge Big Data is all of this
stuff streaming out at us and we've got
to build some refineries so that we can
find the stories that are in the data -
Edwina represent one such refinery hi
the data scientist and Edwina the
marketing mind help develop Tesco's
Clubcard in the 90s
20 million customers have signed up
since exchanging their personal
information for discounts and you could
tell whether someone was buying an item
on promotion because they like the brand
because they if they did that they
bought all the time or because it was on
promotion that week it was that then the
previous week they bought whatever else
was on promotion that category Tesco's
since been forced to defend its loyalty
scheme over privacy concerns back in the
day of center stage it was all about you
are where you live and then as we moved
into grocery and brands it was more
about you are what you eat and that told
us something about lifestyles and
nowadays our interest is you are what
you enjoy or in some cases
like traffic and being stuck in it some
places a crowd-sourced insight tool
about crowdsourcing the insight the
needs of passengers in this case by
using an app which asked people to add
comments about their journey and we're
also crowdsourcing from social media
channels like Twitter and do some simple
analysis and sentiment analysis to
understand whether the content is
positive or negative and where it is
there or geolocators using social media
updates online questionnaires and even
weather data the company common place is
working on developing a platform that we
Maps commuter sentiment the goal to make
journeys similar local government
certainly are interested because it has
an opportunity for them to be able to
really understand again you know in real
time what the residents of their city or
neighborhood are thinking and needing so
whether you're catching the train buying
your groceries or going to the theatre
your data is on display and companies
are cashing in Caroline Hyde Bloomberg